معنا من عمان اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير
العسكري والسرج الامريكي حضره اللواء فايز
ما تفسير ما تحققه فاجنر من
نتائج افضل حتى الان في ما يجي الان في
الارض شاهدنا ما يجرا ما جرى في سوليدار
وكذلك ما قد يحدث ايضا في
جمله من الاسباب اولا نبدا بالجانب الجيش
الروسي الجيش الروسي اااه
سقط اكثر من مره او اكثر من اختبار في
اكثر من معركه
بدءا من كيف خارج كيف خرسون الى غير ذلك
كانت هناك السلسله من النكسات وثبت يقين
ان الجيش الروسي رقم 2 في العالم ليس على
مستوى ما كنا نقرا عنه وبالتالي كان هناك
ترهل في المنظومه الاداريه والمنظومه
اللوجستيه بصوره عامه كان هناك فشل في
قياده المعارك الى غير ذلك الان تم احذر
مقاتلي فاجنر مقاتل فاجنر تقديرات 50,000
التقديرات الغربيه تقول ان 10,000 متطوع و
40,000 من السجون الروسيه قدمت لهم ضمانات
اولا بالعفو العام
راتب جيد مقابل خدمه سته اشهر فيما يسمى
قوات الصدمه او الموجات الاولى او راس
الحربه فبالتالي يخضع الى تدريب قسم منهم
تدريب عالي جدا وقسم ليس بالسويه الممتازه
لكن لديهم غايه وهدف ان يقاتل سته اشهر
يتخلص من الحكم ياخذ راتب مجزي كفاله او
تعويضات في حال الاصابه وتعويضات للاهل في
حال همم مقتله اذا هناك مغريات تجعلهم
يقاتل اكثر انضباطا واكثر مهاره لكن الان
الحديث
فاجنر تصدر المشهد لكن دعني ويشير الى
نقطه
تستطيع ان تنفذ مهام محدده
في حرب المدن يعني هل المهام قطع العاتق
فاجنر تختلف عن المهام القاطع على
عاتق الجيش الروسي
لا هو في البدايه هذه المهام كان يجب على
الجيش الروسي ان ينفذها لكن بسبب العيون
التي اعترت ااه المعارك التي خاضها الجيش
الروسي كان لابد من ايجاد قوات اكثر سويه
في التدريب اكثر انضباطا لديهم الدافعيه
ليقوموا
يشكل راس الحربه او قوات الصدمه وهو ما
اشرت له سابقا لكن دائما لو سمحت
يدفع هذا ما ساقوله الان لديهم او سيتم
ايكال مهام محدده مهام محدده خاصه في حرب
المدن لان هذه الحرب هي حرب صعبه تحتاج
مهاره تحتاج اقدام تحتاج معنويه تحتاج
دافعيه بينما في الجانب الاخر في الجيش
هذه الامور شبه مفقوده لكن لن تستطيع هذه
القوه ان تحل محل الجيش الروسي ولو بصوره
جزئيه لانها لا تستطيع من خلال تنظيمها
وتسريحه واعدادها ان تنفذ عمليات على
المستوى العملياتي كعمليات الاختراق
العميق او عمليات الاحاطه او عمليات
الالتفاف في مسرح العمليات اذا هي تبقى
رديفا للجيش الروسي وهي بحاجه الى تغطيه
ناريه جويه ومدفعيه من الروسي لكن هي تكلف
خارج روسيا خارج اوكرانيا قد نسميها
المهام القذره لكن الان في داخل اوكرانيا
واستنادا الى القانون الروسي نقول بدل
كلمه القذره المهام الصعبه طيب وهنا
السؤال اللواء فايز
واشنطن تقول بانها قد تلجا تصنيف هذه
المنظمه او هذه الميليشيا بانها ارهابيه
في المقابل هناك في الجانب الامريكي
بلاكوتر على سبيل المثال وبالتالي
كيف يتم التصنيف هذه الحاله
يعني هذا هو التصريف تصريف امريكي هل هناك
قائمه ولائحه كبيره جدا منظمه التحرير حتى
لغايه هذه اللحظه لم يتم تصويب الامر كليا
يعني دعني اقول فيما يتعلق بالعالم الغربي
لا يميز ما بين عن الان قد اخرج خارج
السياق حول اوكرانيا لا يعني لا يتم
التمييز بين المقاومه الوطنيه للمشروعه
والجماعات الارهابيه وهذا ما لا عن حماس
من وجهه نظرنا وجهه نظري شخصيا هي مقاومه
مشروع روعه امريكا هي تعتبر تنظيم ارهابي
لهذا السبب لي اعتبرت بلاك ووتر تنظيما
قانونيا يخضع للقوانين الامريكي ولكن بلاك
ووتر مارس كثير من الاعمال الاجراميه في
العراق على سبيل المثال اذا هذا هو
التصنيف امريكي هكذا هي ترى
من عمان لواء فائزه الدويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي شكرا جزيلا لك